I'm always confused as to whether this
is Dylan McDermott or Dermot Mulroney
because Hollywood always speaks to of
everything yes mom you should sit by the
fire watch Breaking Bad this will be
very confusing when this guy starts
watching the final season and he sees
General Edward Clegg helping Walter
White disappear and not to mention one
of Jack's white supremacist gang showing
up out of nowhere to help with the white
house attack Lily thinks that if it puts
a cap and glasses on the kid I'm not
going to notice that it's the same exact
kid when 18 months pass john cale for
1980 no no he was minted in 1980
remember I'm a coin in the United States
Army I was mented in the Year 1980 in
the shot the president is on marine one
at night but in the next shot he's in
some sort of Korean bomber plane about
to attack the White House during the day
and I don't know why Clint Eastwood made
a cameo in this but there he is
Morgan Freeman was clearly the president
in a previous shot but now he's the
Speaker of the House when did he get a
demotion is it because he was focused on
the Comets headed towards Earth instead
of the immediate threat to the White
House oh I see this makes perfect sense
now Jason Clarke is in this movie which
completely explains why we saw they'd
instead of Abraham Lincoln at the
Lincoln Memorial earlier but why is he a
bad guy now
where's the peoc considering when Mike
asked you the question earlier how many
feet from the Oval Office to the peoc
elevator and you answered it perfectly
why do you need to know where it is all
the sudden White House armory somehow
restocks itself after the bad guys
clearly took all the guns earlier there
are still more guys they had to kill
after that airplane went around and shot
everyone up war preacher why did you
even bother getting maintenance guys to
infiltrate the White House when you were
just gonna blow the front door down
anyway but god this plane is stupid sure
she's fine we're in the safest house in
the world
these are surely words that will come
back to haunt you want a news program
three and a half minutes later White
House the most protected building on
earth has fallen see people need to stop
jinxing not since the British burned
down the White House in the war of 1812
boy it sure was nice of the movie to go
through that whole exposition on the war
of 1812 so that this news reporters line
could pay off white house burned down
yeah yeah war of 1812 glasses wait a
damn minute I thought that one of the
president's security guys had to do some
sort of fingerprint match to get into
the peoc but now the president has to do
some sort of retinal scan and a library
followed by a voice match to get there
good confused
look if you wanna have this depressing
shot of the American flag flying off the
White House fine but don't tell me the
White House is still intact after the
aliens attacked so many fun things are
going on right now it's impossible to
figure out
we have to reinsure the White House the
president is in his limo with Channing
Tatum Gerard Butler's looking confused I
mean to quote a favorite reporter of
mine we don't know what is happening
exactly 10 years I've known Bobby twice
the guys saved my life John McClane
writes down names that the bad guys
don't even mention you must be able to
hear things on top of the elevator that
we can't hear inside the elevator
you are the Acting President of the
United States god I wish they'd make up
their mind about whether this guy's
president or not
[Music]
still the Secretary of Defense yet later
though waste all sorts of time trying to
kill the new Secretary of Defense
because it's convenient for the plot
really can't believe after Benjamin
Gates failed that his earlier attempt to
get into the president's desk he hired a
bunch of North Koreans to assault the
White House just to get his hands on the
next clue but no doubt he'll get away
with it because treasure all this movie
is really is a series of people climbing
up things later on John will have this
kid climbing up an air duct while he
takes out one of the henchmen down below
I should have called this movie climbing
up dangerous I don't even know why they
need the stick hit they already have
this woman doing all the computer stuff
I mean while the movie has completely
forgotten about Theo this team of
terrorists has more hackers than the
movie hackers you want to remove the
president from power sir I can see why
she'd be upset about that since her
boyfriend Harvey Dent it's the current
president but her best friend's
confidant Lucius Fox is the Acting
President and this movie can't decide
which president it wants my name is
Martin James Walker chief of the
presidential detail of the United States
Secret Service that's so odd to me
I thought Angela Bassett was the one
running the Secret Service in fact
didn't I hear her basically telling
James Woods what's what just a second
ago the fact that it recorded static is
and would interest me what interests me
is that it recorded approximately 18
hours
that is interesting isn't it yeah that's
gonna be fine this fuck just won't
listen to directions Willie remember
what the president said to him earlier
stop lying the children what a dick this
guy is Mookie dodges to be done of
course they are everyone saw that
earlier you were there and it's their
infiltration of Washington that has us
in this mess right now when did they
decide to take the presidency for Morgan
Freeman again this guy does a lot of
screwing up off-screen that we never see
not learning from any of their mistakes
the president once again calls for an
aerial attack on the White House after
the previous one went so badly
we've got moments at the Federal Reserve
but you're in Washington DC and McLean
just saw bad guys taking money from the
Federal Reserve in New York City there's
gold in the Federal Reserve and they
took a load of it so where the hell is
this happening right now you right in
the ear it is clearly not clear I don't
know how this government is running with
the former vice president calling the
shots and the former Speaker of the
House calling the shots Capitol building
is intact in the shot when it got blown
up earlier in the movie not by her they
have to come by ground a fuku can have
of this because they have javelin
missiles I wish they make up their mind
with these top-secret weapons actually
are here they call it the Hydra six you
got a port to a submission they got the
Hydra six and now they're calling them
javelin missiles look if you want to
have the American flag fall off the
White House again don't tell me it
happened earlier and someone stuck
another flag up there I'm still angry
that the whole White House was blown up
and then there was still some White
House left for the helicopter to do even
more damage and yet in this shot the
White House just keeps building itself
back up like there are secret
contractors doing work during a
terrorist attack
look either the helicopter blew up when
a crashing of the White House or it
stayed intact enough for helicopter
blades to come through the ceiling can't
be for both so make a goddamn decision
these countdown clocks are way out of
sync with each other and I don't know
which one to believe anymore we're going
to need to sway you in soon what
happened a Morgan Freeman confirmed yeah
sure
to have been among those killed when the
Blackhawk helicopter went down in flames
on the White House north wall the news
media continues to report the president
dead without a body even after he
survived us explosion - this crashing
and wasn't dead earlier these fictional
news outlets are probably worse than the
real news outlets mud Walker now has the
ability to launch missiles at any target
in the continental United States no he
doesn't the hacker chick still needs the
president missile launch code to do that
you ever think this movie might have
been two different scripts at one point
and they film both of them and made it
into one movie I've said let's show
massive troop movements in Russia
Pakistan and the Arabian Peninsula then
why hasn't this movie dying already what
is that what are you doing this is the
nuclear football is that what they've
been planning this whole time no wonder
Jimmie Foxx throws up every time he goes
out to play and this dickhead is a team
doctor for Christ's sake in fact that's
probably extremely nuclear football if
you have two presidents on the same team
once a quarterback and the other is the
offensive coordinator sending those men
in was the most courageous thing you
ever did in your life you were a true
commander-in-chief for five minutes look
I know all white guys are racist but the
person who was president for five
minutes in this movie was Morgan Freeman
not Jamie Foxx sir we have nuclear
missiles spinning up on the Albuquerque
first you see the missiles are in the
silos on US soil now you're saying the
missiles are on submarines - man I don't
know whether to be afraid for the US or
the entire world look little girl if the
pilots aren't gonna pay any attention to
John McLean's waving fire around it sure
is aren't gonna care about some dumb
flag waving how many times is this guy
gonna survive getting shot earlier he
survives this close-range gunshot to the
gut now he survives getting shot and
basically the same spot because he just
happens to have Lincoln's stopwatch to
stop the bullet when did you and Walker
cook this whole thing up look John
either your dad is a mild-mannered coin
collector with anxiety issues or he's a
devious mastermind trying to rule the
world
he can't be both they're goddamn traitor
sir this is in such stark contrast to
the scene earlier when John basically
poured his heart out to his dad in this
scene I don't how you changed so quickly
from that to this maybe he has
miraculous recovery turned him into an
asshole then for whatever reason Jamie
Foxx totally sets up mic so that'll blow
himself up right after he saved his ass
I'll give this movie this I was not
expecting that twist but murdering
president is murder I have no idea how
they plan to get Washington and the
White House rebuilt after this
but place looks amazingly dry after a
huge flood went through it's just open
the gates of hell
[Music]
finishes
Russert hello America it is my unhappy
duty to report to you that the Messiah
has failed this computer enhanced radar
image from Houston shows how the
detonation succeeded however did not
destroy the comet Cerberus has been
deactivated
NORAD confirms servers has been shut
down mr. Forbes good well trained and
well organized the well financed very
slick how's your wife Michael saves
lives too bad she will not save yours
mr. McClane mr. Officer John McClane
hello hey I'm just checking in well Mike
you know I've been trying to I've been
calling you every where are you okay hey
you okay are you okay hey okay probably
this is happening has been busy it's
good you know how about you I've had
stay a little later than I expected
little bit the hospital of my size now
I'm gonna get you and Sam out yeah well
you too I love you
[Music]
we have